Zoe Chace?
Zoe Chace？
Yes Ira Glass?
是吗，Ira Glass？
You brought some tape to play?
你带了录音带过来播放吗？
Yeah. I brought some tape from this trip that I was on recently.
对。我带了一盘录音带，是我最近一次旅行中录的。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago.
Zoe Chace是我们节目的制作人之一。这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《This American Life》。
So on this trip, I was in an interesting room.
那次旅行中，我待在一个有趣的房间里。
A couple ground rules. There will be no safe spaces, no trigger warnings, no microaggressions.
几条基本规则。这里没有安全空间，没有触发预警，没有微冒犯。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
We are going to have-- we're going to have some honest discussion here.
我们要进行——我们要在这里进行一些诚实的讨论。
We're in a huge auditorium surrounded by more than 2,000 conservative college students. It's a bunch of young people in sports coats and ties and dresses and heels.
我们在一个巨大的礼堂里，周围有2000多名保守派大学生。这是一群身穿运动外套、打着领带、穿着连衣裙和高跟鞋的年轻人。
And the media has said, oh, there's no young conservatives out there. You have to be liberal if you're in college. And every single one of you here today-- from all 50 states, by the way-- are here to tell the media, colleges, and the elites that our generation will not embrace socialism.
媒体说，哦，外面没有年轻的保守派了。如果你在大学里，你必须是自由派。而在座的各位——顺便说一下，来自所有50个州——你们今天来到这里是为了告诉媒体、大学和精英们，我们这一代人不会拥护社会主义。
This is Charlie Kirk, and this room is at a big conference he's throwing. Charlie Kirk's organization is called Turning Point USA-- kind of a pumped up version of the College Republicans is how I describe it. And they recruit and train conservative students to be conservative activists on their campuses. Charlie, he's 24. He's preppy. He still technically lives in his parents' house outside Chicago.
这是Charlie Kirk，这个房间就在他举办的一场大型会议上。Charlie Kirk的组织叫“美国转折点”（Turning Point USA）——我将其描述为“美国大学生共和党人”的升级版。他们招募并培训保守派学生，使他们成为校园里的保守派活动家。Charlie今年24岁，穿着时髦。他实际上仍然住在芝加哥郊外父母的家里。
Technically means--
“实际上”的意思是——
Means that's his domicile. But he's on the road more than 300 days out of the year. He founded this group something like five years ago. They have a ton of money from conservative donors. This year, they're going to have a budget close to $14 to $15 million, someone close to the organization told me. Took place in a really fancy hotel right near Mar-a-Lago, actually.
意思是那是他的住所。但他一年中超过300天都在路上。这个组织是他大约五年前创立的。他们从保守派捐赠者那里获得了大量的资金。据组织内部人士告诉我，他们今年的预算接近1400万到1500万美元。这场会议实际上是在离海湖庄园非常近的一家高档酒店举行的。
The son of the president of the United States, Donald Trump Jr.
美国总统的儿子，小唐纳德·特朗普。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Wait, Donald Trump Jr. was there?
等等，小唐纳德·特朗普也在那里？
Yeah. Charlie Kirk, the head of the organization, and Donald Trump Jr. are friends. So this conference, it's premised on the idea that there's an important battleground right now in America that conservatives are losing. They've been losing this battle for years. That's college campuses, college campuses overrun by liberal bias. Conservatives feel embattled. They feel outnumbered.
是的。该组织负责人Charlie Kirk和小唐纳德·特朗普是朋友。所以，这次会议的前提是，美国目前有一个重要的战场，而保守派正在输掉这场战争。多年来，他们一直在这场战斗中节节败退。那就是大学校园，被自由派偏见占领的大学校园。保守派感到四面楚歌。他们感到人数处于劣势。
Now, this is nothing new, conservatives saying this.
现在，保守派这样说已经不是什么新鲜事了。
True. And the Koch brothers and other conservative donors are throwing millions of dollars at this. To change our politics, they want to change our culture. To change the culture, you have to change universities. And the speakers at this conference, they make it sound like this is a life or death moment.
没错。科赫兄弟和其他保守派捐赠者正在投入数百万美元。为了改变我们的政治，他们想改变我们的文化。要改变文化，就必须改变大学。这次会议上的发言者让他们听起来好像这是一个生死攸关的时刻。
We are in a nonviolent-- and I pray to God it remains nonviolent-- civil war. There are unbridgeable gaps between left and right.
我们正处于一场非暴力——我祈求上帝它保持非暴力——的内战中。左派和右派之间存在着不可逾越的鸿沟。
We are at war, right? We're not debating Obamacare. We're not debating tax cuts. We're not debating the border. We're debating America.
我们处于战争状态，对吧？我们不是在辩论奥巴马医改。我们不是在辩论减税。我们不是在辩论边境。我们是在辩论美国。
But all of you are now messengers. All of you are now part of the fight. All of you are the people who are going to go back to your campuses and convert 10 other people. You should always wear that target proudly on your back because they will come for you. And when they come for you, the only way those bullets are going to bounce off is if you're made of steel. Thanks so much.
但你们所有人现在都是信使。你们所有人现在都是这场斗争的一部分。你们所有人都是那些准备回到校园并转化其他10个人的人。你应该始终自豪地戴着那个目标在背上，因为他们会来找你的。当他们来找你时，只有当你由钢铁制成时，那些子弹才会弹开。非常感谢。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Well, I have to say, those are some very powerful speakers.
嗯，我不得不说，那些是非常有力的发言者。
They are doing a good job for those kids.
他们为那些孩子做得很好。
Yeah. Here's the new thing I learned at this conference, is that there are now outside groups and a whole infrastructure fighting this war on American campuses. The tinder is there for the fire, for sure. People are ready for a crazy fight on all sides. But now, there are a number of relatively new, big, well-funded national organizations like this one, like Turning Point USA, which are fanning the flames and spreading the fire.
是的。我在这次会议上学到的新东西是，现在有外部团体和整个基础设施在这些美国校园里进行这场战争。火种确实存在。各方的人们都准备好迎接一场疯狂的战斗了。但现在，有许多相对较新、规模大、资金充足的全国性组织，就像这个“美国转折点”一样，正在煽风点火，扩大火势。
And I would say that that is what our program is about today. We're going to see this play out on one campus and see just how easy it is for these things to blow up into a huge, raging wildfire. But Zoe, before we get to that, what exactly happens at this conference?
我想这就是我们今天节目的内容。我们将看到这种情况在某个校园里上演，看看这些事情演变成一场巨大的、肆虐的野火是多么容易。但是Zoe，在我们进入那个话题之前，会议上到底发生了什么？
The conference is for tactical advice on how to fight this war on campus. So for example-- so invite a conservative speaker to campus.
会议提供关于如何在校园里进行这场战争的战术建议。例如——邀请一位保守派演讲者到校园。
You don't just have a right to bring people to campus. You don't just have a right to stand up for yourself and speak out. I think you have an obligation.
你不仅有权带人到校园。你不仅有权站出来为自己说话。我认为你还有义务这样做。
Now, in some cases, a college will try to stop the speaker. They'll think they're too controversial or charge a big security fee for that speaker. And there's a panel for what to do if that happens. The panel is called "Sue Your School 101: Knowing and Defending the First Amendment on Campus."
现在，在某些情况下，大学会试图阻止演讲者。他们会认为他们太具争议性，或者向演讲者收取高额的安全费用。有一个小组讨论专门探讨如果发生这种情况该怎么办。该小组被称为“起诉你的学校入门：了解并捍卫校园里的第一修正案”。
Anybody here from Wisconsin?
这里有人来自威斯康星州吗？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Awesome. So we have sued your university system seven times. So thanks. You guys are great.
太棒了。所以我们已经起诉了你们的大学系统七次。所以谢谢。你们太棒了。
There are panels like "Socialism is for Suckers," "48 Liberal Lies," "Was Jesus a Socialist?"
还有像“社会主义是给傻瓜准备的”、“48个自由派谎言”、“耶稣是社会主义者吗？”这样的小组讨论。
I'm going to guess the answer to that is no?
我猜答案是“不”吧？
It is no. He was not. At night, the nighttime activity was a protest. Basically, anti-Trumpers of West Palm Beach came out to protest this conference.
是“不”。他不是。晚上，夜间的活动是抗议。基本上，西棕榈滩的反特朗普人士出来抗议这次会议。
And honestly, it seemed almost too perfect, as though the conference had planned it. They did not. But it just felt like a way to get your conservative jollies out by yelling about some of the stuff they've been talking about all day. There were these super eclectic chants, like "taxation is theft."
老实说，这看起来太完美了，好像会议组织方策划好了一样。他们并没有。但这感觉就像是一种通过对他们整天讨论的一些话题进行大喊大叫来发泄保守派情绪的方式。那里有一些超级折中的口号，比如“税收就是盗窃”。
Taxation is theft! Taxation is theft! Taxation is theft!
税收就是盗窃！税收就是盗窃！税收就是盗窃！
This one is hard to hear. This girl in the back yells out, "How many genders are there?"
这一句很难听清。后面那个女孩大喊：“有多少种性别？”
How many genders are there?
有多少种性别？
Two.
两种。
How many genders are there?
有多少种性别？
Two.
两种。
This insistence from Turning Point kids that there are only two genders, that gets brought up a lot, and it feels kind of random. And I figured out it's kind of a battle cry for these kids on the right. They're just basically saying, you are irrational, to the left. Of course, that dismissal of transgender and non-binary people can and often does come across as incredibly hateful.
“美国转折点”的孩子们坚持认为只有两种性别，这被频繁提出，感觉有点随机。我发现这基本上是这些右翼孩子们的战斗口号。他们基本上是在对左派说，你们是不理性的。当然，这种对跨性别和非二元性别者的蔑视可以，而且通常确实会让人觉得非常充满仇恨。
So they're chanting this stuff?
所以他们在高喊这些东西？
Yeah. And making videos. In fact, that was a big thing this conference seemed to be about, was making videos. How to make videos to fight back against the left on their campuses. There were a bunch of panels about that-- the art of the click, how to make political viral content, things like that. The idea is, even if you're isolated on your campus, there's a huge network out there of conservative news that's hungry for the video and will tell your story.
是的。还在制作视频。事实上，这次会议似乎很大一部分是关于制作视频的。如何制作视频来反击校园里的左派。有很多关于这个的小组讨论——点击的艺术，如何制作政治病毒式内容，诸如此类。其理念是，即使你在校园里孤立无援，外面也有一个巨大的保守派新闻网络，渴望这些视频，并会讲述你的故事。
If you have a cell phone, then you are now a reporter. If you are on a college campus, you have things that are worth covering.
如果你有一部手机，那么你现在就是一名记者。如果你在大学校园里，你就有值得报道的事情。
This is Ben Shapiro, a big name conservative speaker who also founded The Daily Wire.
这是Ben Shapiro，一位大名鼎鼎的保守派演讲者，也是《每日连线》（The Daily Wire）的创始人。
I run a publication. It has about 100 million page views a month. If you email me with your story and we can verify it and check it, make sure it's true, we'll run with it. And this is true for Fox News, this is true for Daily Caller, this is true for Breitbart. This is true for all of the major right-wing publications. And so granting exposure is the easiest way to bring shame to a lot of these folks who deserve it.
我经营一家出版物。它每个月有大约1亿的页面浏览量。如果你通过电子邮件将你的故事发给我，我们可以验证并核实，确保它是真实的，我们就会发布它。福克斯新闻也是如此，每日传呼者（Daily Caller）也是如此，布赖特巴特新闻（Breitbart）也是如此。所有主要的右翼出版物都是如此。所以，给予曝光是让许多应受惩罚的人蒙羞的最简单方法。
At this other panel called "Fighting the PC Police," this guy, Cabot Phillips-- he's a clean cut 24-year-old guy. He's just adored. It seems like everyone in the session knows him. And both of his sessions were packed. He gave tips on exactly, step by step, how do you make an effective video on your phone?
在另一个名为“打击政治正确警察”的小组讨论上，这个叫Cabot Phillips的人——他是一个24岁的干净利落的家伙。他简直被人崇拜。看起来会议中的每个人都认识他。他的两场会议都挤满了人。他给出了关于如何用手机制作有效视频的具体步骤建议。
As far as video goes-- we all know this. How do we film our videos, guys?
就视频而言——我们都知道这一点。伙计们，我们怎么拍视频？
Horizontal.
横屏。
Horizontal, heck yeah. If you film your videos vertically, you are not worthy of love.
横屏，见鬼，没错。如果你竖着拍视频，你就配不上爱。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You're not a good person.
你不是个好人。
And Cabot is the media director with a news site whose entire purpose is to document and publicize liberalism run amok on campus. It's called Campus Reform. They pay conservative students at colleges across the country to be correspondents, scouring their campuses for stories. Some are small, like, "College Republicans email list used to, quote, 'identify the racists,'" or "college turns gym into man-free space."
Cabot是一家新闻网站的媒体主管，该网站的全部宗旨是记录和宣传校园里泛滥的自由主义。它叫“校园改革”（Campus Reform）。他们付钱给全国各地的大学里的保守派学生作为通讯员，在校园里搜罗故事。有些很小，比如，“大学共和党人电子邮件列表被用来识别种族主义者”，或者“大学把体育馆变成了无男性空间”。
I love that these sound like Onion headlines, but from a right-wing perspective.
我喜欢这些听起来像《洋葱新闻》的头条，但却是从右翼的角度出发的。
I know. But these are real things that happen. One of them was about students demanding free tampons in both men and women's bathrooms. They did this by painting their pants with fake blood stains. It's called a bleed-in. That's a story.
我知道。但这些都是现实中发生的事情。其中一个关于学生要求在男女厕所都提供免费卫生棉。他们通过用假血迹染红裤子来做到这一点。这被称为“流血抗议”。这是一个故事。
And so all of these are basically conservatives writing about how crazy liberals are on the campuses or how hard it is to be a conservative on campus.
所以所有这些基本上都是保守派在写关于自由派在校园里有多疯狂，或者在校园里做保守派有多难。
Right. One prime type of video that Cabot from Campus Reform talked about is one that you would take when, say, you're out with your little table and you're trying to sign people up for your Turning Point USA chapter on your campus. You're in the middle of the quad. And there's this thing that's come up on public universities lately that I just found out about recently. It's the free speech zone. The free speech zone is this area of campus where all political activity, any protest or political advocacy, it's confined to one area.
没错。Cabot提到的那种主要视频是你，比如说，当你带着你的小桌子在校园里试图招募人们加入你的“美国转折点”分部时拍的。你在方阵中间。最近在公立大学里出现了一件事，我最近才发现。那就是“言论自由区”。言论自由区是校园里所有政治活动、任何抗议或政治宣传被限制在一个区域的地方。
A lot of times, people don't realize it's completely unconstitutional.
很多时候，人们没有意识到它是完全违宪的。
And if you are tabling outside of the free speech zone, someone from the university may come up to you and tell you to move to the free speech zone. And that's your cue.
如果你在言论自由区外摆摊，大学里的人可能会走过来让你搬到言论自由区。这就是你的提示。
Whip your phone out. Start filming. Stay calm. Be polite. There's no need to be a jerk. But just ask them. I'm not saying I won't leave, but what will happen if I choose not to leave?
掏出你的手机。开始拍摄。保持冷静。保持礼貌。没必要当混蛋。但只管问他们。我不是说我不会离开，但如果我选择不离开会发生什么？
The very best video to get, it seems, the creme de la creme-- this is the impression I got-- it's filming triggered snowflakes. You know a snowflake?
拍到最好的视频，看起来，精华中的精华——这是我得到的印象——是拍摄被触发的“雪花”。你知道什么是雪花吗？
Yes, of course. A snowflake is a liberal who is easily offended.
是的，当然。雪花就是容易被冒犯的自由派。
Right. Like, say a right-wing student group's posters are torn down. They may be torn down by snowflakes who are triggered by those posters. Cabot plays this one super viral video of a girl in an audience at an event screaming, "Get your hate speech off our campus. Get your hate speech off our campus." His point is that a snowflake can be triggered by your very existence on campus.
没错。比如，假设一个右翼学生团体的海报被撕掉了。它们可能是被那些被海报触发的雪花撕掉的。Cabot播放了一个超级病毒式传播的视频，一个女孩在活动观众席中尖叫：“把你们的仇恨言论从我们的校园里拿走。把你们的仇恨言论从我们的校园里拿走。”他的观点是，一个雪花可能会因为你在校园里的存在而被触发。
And they do this thing where they will just throw out name calling. That's the first tactic they use, where they'll say, you're a racist. You're a bigot homophobe. You are a part of the patriarchy, whatever that means. You're all these things.
他们确实会做这种事，扔出人身攻击。那是他们使用的第一个策略，他们会说，你是种族主义者。你是偏执的同性恋恐惧症患者。你是父权制的一部分，不管那意味着什么。你是所有这些东西。
And it kind of sucks getting called that. No matter how untrue it is-- which it is, untrue. No matter how untrue it is, it's still like, I don't really want to get called that on campus. So maybe I won't speak up because I don't want to have to deal with this.
被那样称呼感觉很糟糕。无论它多么不真实——它确实是不真实的。无论它多么不真实，它依然像，我真的不想在校园里被那样称呼。所以也许我不会发言，因为我不想处理这些事。
They don't just want you guys to be quiet. OK? The left on your campus doesn't just want you to stop talking. They want you to completely be off of their campus because your ideas make them feel that unsafe.
他们不仅想让你们安静。好的？你们校园里的左派不仅仅想让你们停止说话。他们想让你们完全离开他们的校园，因为你们的观点让他们感到不安全。
He's right. A lot of people on the left do say that ideas on the right make him feel unsafe. So things can explode and get out of hand really quickly.
他是对的。左派中的许多人确实说右派的观点让他们感到不安全。所以事情可能会迅速爆发并失控。
Well, today on our program, we see a brand new Turning Point recruit head out and try the things that Turning Point USA tells students to do and trains them to do. During this moment in our history where everybody assumes the absolute worst about each other, we watch this newbie head right into the thick of it-- a sophomore, 19 years old when this starts.
今天在我们的节目中，我们看到一名新招募的“美国转折点”成员开始尝试“美国转折点”告诉学生们要做并培训他们做的事情。在我们历史上的这一时刻，每个人都对彼此抱有最坏的打算，我们看着这个新人直接进入了矛盾的核心——一个在大二时就开始这一切的19岁年轻人。
Our reporter for this story is somebody who knows this world well. He's been covering these fights on campus for The Chronicle of Higher Education. His name Steve Kolowich. And let's just get right to it. Here he is.
我们这个故事的记者是一个非常了解这个世界的人。他一直为《高等教育纪事报》报道这些校园冲突。他叫Steve Kolowich。让我们直接开始吧。他在这里。
Katie Mullen knew she wanted to start a Turning Point chapter at her school after she went to her first conference, the Young Women's Leadership Summit last summer.
Katie Mullen在去年夏天参加了她的第一次会议——青年女性领导力峰会后，就知道她想在学校开一个“转折点”分部。
And it was just really empowering in the fact that the whole conference, we were just talking about how there's no really glass ceiling. There's just skies above. There's nothing that we can't do. And just being around that many women, I think, just as a whole, was really empowering.
这确实令人振奋，事实上在整个会议期间，我们只是在谈论根本没有所谓的玻璃天花板。只有头顶的蓝天。没有什么我们做不到的事情。我认为，作为一个整体，能和那么多女性在一起本身就非常令人振奋。
The first time Katie remembers having a strong political feeling was in high school, while listening to Rush Limbaugh with her grandmother. He was criticizing Obamacare in a way that really resonated with her. She became the kind of teenager who would write to her congressman.
Katie记得第一次有强烈政治感受是在高中时，当时她和祖母一起听Rush Limbaugh的节目。他批评奥巴马医改的方式真的引起了她的共鸣。她变成了那种会写信给国会议员的青少年。
She arrived at the University of Nebraska-Lincoln, UNL, just as the 2016 presidential election was entering the home stretch. Most of her friends on campus weren't that into politics. She liked the idea of being connected to other young people who were just as excited about it as she was. Turning Point looked fun. Its founder, Charlie Kirk, wasn't much older than she was. And he was really good at Twitter.
她抵达内布拉斯加大学林肯分校（UNL）时，正值2016年总统大选进入最后阶段。她在校园里的朋友大多数对政治不感兴趣。她喜欢与那些同样对此感到兴奋的其他年轻人建立联系的想法。“转折点”看起来很有趣。它的创始人Charlie Kirk并不比她大多少。而且他在推特上非常活跃。
Last summer, she went to her second Turning Point conference. This one was for chapter leaders. She met Charlie Kirk. She made new friends. And she came back to campus in the fall, fired up to spread the gospel of liberty and capitalism.
去年夏天，她去了她的第二次“转折点”会议。这次是为分部领导人准备的。她见到了Charlie Kirk。她结交了新朋友。她在秋季回到校园，准备传播自由和资本主义的福音。
On August 25 last year, Katie tried tabling on campus for the first time on the plaza outside the student union. Turning Point had sent her a starter kit with stickers and buttons that said things like "Socialism Sucks" and "I Heart Capitalism." Her club wasn't official yet, so Katie wanted to do some recruiting.
去年8月25日，Katie第一次尝试在学生会外的广场上摆摊。转折点寄给她一套入门套件，里面有贴纸和徽章，上面写着“社会主义烂透了”和“我爱资本主义”。她的俱乐部还没正式成立，所以Katie想招募一些人。
Can you sort of give me your pitch? If I were a student coming up to your table, what would you say?
你能稍微介绍一下你的宣传词吗？如果我是一个走到你摊位前的学生，你会说什么？
OK. Well, it was my first time out there, so I was a little-- I don't think I was a really good saleswoman. I was more timid that day, waiting for people to come up to me. But people passing by, I would ask them how they felt about capitalism or what their belief on socialism was, and just get a conversation started.
好吧。嗯，那是我第一次去那里，所以我有点——我不认为我是个很好的销售员。那天我比较胆小，等着人们走过来。但是对于路过的人，我会问他们对资本主义感觉如何，或者他们对社会主义的信仰是什么，就这样开始对话。
Katie set up her table in the place where there is a lot of foot traffic, just like Turning Point says to do. And sure enough, along came a university employee.
Katie像“转折点”所建议的那样，把桌子设在人流量大的地方。果然，一个大学员工走了过来。
We're going to have to ask you guys to move this to the free speech zone or we'll have to have UNLPD remove you. It's completely up to you.
我们得让你们搬到言论自由区，否则我们将不得不让UNL警察把你们带走。这完全取决于你们。
But isn't this a public university?
但这不是一所公立大学吗？
Not with propaganda. You can free speech all you want, but you cannot hand out propaganda.
不是带着宣传品。你可以随心所欲地发表言论，但你不能分发宣传品。
But isn't this a public university?
但这不是一所公立大学吗？
Katie stood her ground. She recorded the interaction on her phone.
Katie坚守阵地。她用手机记录了这次互动。
We've always been told, pics or it didn't happen. So it's kind of the same thing-- videos or it didn't happen.
我们总是被告知，有图有真相。所以这也一样——有视频才有真相。
Free speech zone is over here on the other side of the Memorial Plaza sign.
言论自由区在纪念广场标志的那一边。
That video alone would have been a good get for Turning Point, confirmation that yet another college campus wanted to silence conservative ideas. But then, bigger game wandered onto the plaza, a full-throated liberal zealot.
单单那段视频对于“转折点”来说就已经是个不错的收获了，证实了又一所大学校园想要压制保守派观点。但随后，更大的猎物闯入了广场，一个全面狂热的自由派狂热分子。
I saw the table for Turning Point USA. And I was like, oh, hell no. I was like, not on my campus. No, no, no, no, no.
我看到了“美国转折点”的摊位。我就想，哦，去你的。我想，不在我的校园里。不，不，不，不，不。
This is Courtney Lawton. She's 47. She's getting her PhD in English. And at the time, she was also an instructor in the English department, teaching freshman writing classes.
这是Courtney Lawton。她47岁。她正在攻读英语博士学位。当时，她还是英语系的讲师，教大一写作课。
They were out trolling for liberals. And they got a live one on the line with me.
他们出来钓自由派。而他们在我身上钓到了一条大的。
Courtney had read about Turning Point and believed it was far more sinister than Katie's table made it appear. She first learned about it because of the Professor Watchlist, which is pretty much exactly what it sounds like. Turning Point publishes the names of professors who have said things that are offensive to its values and puts their photos on the website. Offenses that can land the professor on the Watchlist include sniping at Republicans, being anti-Israel, writing too urgently about white privilege or the patriarchy, or saying the NRA is partly to blame for mass shootings.
Courtney读过关于“转折点”的文章，认为它比Katie的摊位所表现出来的要阴险得多。她第一次听说它是因为“教授观察名单”，这名副其实。转折点公布了那些说了冒犯其价值观的话的教授名单，并将他们的照片放在网站上。可以让教授进入“观察名单”的罪行包括抨击共和党人、反以色列、关于白人特权或父权制的文章写得太急迫，或者说全国步枪协会（NRA）应对大规模枪击事件负有部分责任。
Courtney knew of professors who had been bombarded with violent or hateful messages, and even placed on leave or fired after having their misdeeds trumpeted by conservative media outlets like Campus Reform. Courtney thinks Turning Point puts a target on professors' backs.
Courtney知道一些教授在被保守派媒体（如“校园改革”）宣传了他们的“罪行”后，遭到暴力或仇恨信息的轰炸，甚至被迫停职或解雇。Courtney认为“转折点”把矛头指向了教授。
They harass professors. They provoke them. They send agent provocateurs to college campuses. They also want to remove the humanities from the curriculum if that curriculum is not sufficiently conservative.
他们骚扰教授。他们挑衅他们。他们派遣挑衅者到大学校园。如果课程不够保守，他们还想把人文科学从课程中删除。
Courtney left the plaza and rushed back to her office, grabbed some poster board and a marker, and scrawled a sign that said--
Courtney离开了广场，冲回办公室，抓起一张海报板和一支记号笔，潦草地写了一块标志——
"Just say no to neo-Fascism."
“对新法西斯主义说不。”
When Courtney says neo-Fascism, she basically means the platform of the current Republican Party-- anti-abortion, pro-gun, hard-line on immigration. My producer Dana Chivvis and I talked to Courtney together.
当Courtney说新法西斯主义时，她基本上是指现任共和党人的政纲——反堕胎、支持枪支、移民强硬路线。我的制作人Dana Chivvis和我一起采访了Courtney。
Can you be pro-Trump and not a fascist?
你能支持特朗普而不是法西斯吗？
Nope, I don't think so.
不能，我不这么认为。
Who did you write the sign for?
你为谁写的这个标语？
People walking by. People who were thinking that, oh, this looks like a cool-- oh, no. This is neo-Fascism. Whoa. You know? [LAUGHS]
路过的人。那些认为，哦，这看起来像个很酷的——哦，不。这是新法西斯主义。哇。你知道吗？[笑]
She made the sign and went back to the plaza where Katie was.
她制作了标志，回到了Katie所在的广场。
She was set up in this area where all of the crazy street preachers are, the Jehovah's Witnesses come. She was in that area. She was on the mall, OK? And I'm like, fair game. You're on the mall. Here we go.
她设在这个所有疯狂的街头传教士所在的地方，耶和华见证人来的地方。她在那个区域。她在购物中心，好吗？我就想，公平博弈。你在购物中心。我们要开始了。
And I went to stand in front of the table maybe about a meter away, walking back and forth in front of the table. And I had started chanting, "No KKK, no neo-Nazi USA."
我走到摊位前大约一米的地方，在摊位前走来走去。我开始喊着：“没有三K党，没有新纳粹美国。”
(CHANTING) No KKK! No neo-Fascist USA! Fight white nationalism! Fight white supremacy!
（口号）没有三K党！没有新法西斯美国！反对白人民族主义！反对白人至上！
The student, Katie, was taken aback. She didn't go out that day to make a video of a snowflake. It was her first day. She says she really just wanted to sign up some students and try out her patter.
这个叫Katie的学生吃了一惊。她那天出来不是为了拍一个“雪花”视频。那是她的第一天。她说她真的只是想签下一些学生，试试她的那套话。
Of course, she understood this kind of thing might happen. But now she was in the middle of it, and it was kind of intense. And she was alone. And here was Courtney, treating her like some kind of race warrior.
当然，她明白这种事可能会发生。但现在她正处于其中，而且情况有点紧张。而且她是一个人。而这里是Courtney，把她当作某种种族战士。
It was humiliating. I mean, I don't think anyone wants to be associated-- well, any normal person would not want to be associated with the KKK or being racist.
那是一种羞辱。我的意思是，我不认为任何人想与——好吧，任何正常人都不会想与三K党联系在一起，或者被认为是种族主义者。
(CHANTING) No KKK! No NRA! No neo-Fascist USA! Fight white nationalism!
（口号）没有三K党！没有NRA！没有新法西斯美国！反对白人民族主义！
I mean, at first I almost laughed. It was like, oh, gosh. What's she doing? And that's when I actually first got just my Snapchat out, I mean, I Snapchat everything. She was screaming. So I just took a video. But then it started progressively getting more intense and worse. And I started getting a lot more nervous.
我的意思是，起初我差点笑出来。就像，哦，天哪。她在干什么？那就是我第一次拿出 Snapchat，我的意思是，我把所有事都发到 Snapchat 上。她在尖叫。所以我只是录了个视频。但后来情况逐渐变得更激烈、更糟了。我开始感到紧张多了。
When they're saying, "no KKK," and they're saying you're racist, were you like, what the hell are you talking about?
当他们喊着“没有三K党”，说你是种族主义者时，你是不是想，你在胡说什么？
I just thought they were saying it because I was conservative. To some people who are on the way left, I would say they want to say all conservatives are racist.
我只是认为他们这么说是因为我是保守派。对于一些偏左的人，我会说他们想把所有保守派都说成是种族主义者。
Courtney says she was using "KKK" as shorthand for "you're racist." She says Turning Point tries to provoke racial resentment in white people. And race is something they talk about a fair amount. Charlie Kirk, the founder, has called the concept of white privilege a, quote, "myth and a lie." He says it's a racist idea.
Courtney说她用“三K党”作为“你是种族主义者”的速记。她说“转折点”试图煽动白人的种族怨恨。种族是他们谈论很多的话题。创始人Charlie Kirk称“白人特权”这一概念为“神话和谎言”。他说这是一个种族主义的想法。
Turning Point also thinks affirmative action is racist, a point it tries to make by encouraging its campus chapters to hold affirmative action bake sales. They sell cookies to black students for $0.50. White students have to pay $2. All that, to Courtney, is KKK-ish.
“转折点”还认为平权行动是种族主义，他们通过鼓励校园分部举办平权行动义卖来试图证明这一点。他们以0.5美元的价格向黑人学生出售饼干。白人学生必须支付2美元。所有这些，对Courtney来说，都是三K党那一套。
I mean, it's a loaded term, but sometimes you have to use hyperbole to get people's attention too. It's a rhetorical thing.
我的意思是，这是一个沉重的词，但有时你也必须使用夸张来吸引人们的注意。这是一种修辞手法。
I've watched this one video Katie took a bunch of times, and it always feels awkward. Usually, campus protests involve large groups of people whose chanting and sign waving makes sense because they're in a crowd.
我看了很多次Katie拍的那段视频，它总是让人感到尴尬。通常，校园抗议涉及大群人，他们的口号和挥舞的旗帜很有道理，因为他们在人群中。
But in Katie's video, Courtney is mostly alone. She's pacing with her sign, calling out like a carnival barker. The plaza is huge and mostly empty. Someone on a bike whizzes by, tumbleweed style. Katie walked out from behind her table to get a better shot. She starts narrating.
但在Katie的视频中，Courtney大多是孤身一人。她拿着牌子踱步，像个嘉年华叫卖员一样大喊大叫。广场巨大且大多是空的。有人骑着自行车飞驰而过，就像风滚草一样。Katie从摊位后面走出来，为了拍到更好的镜头。她开始解说。
Tabling for Turning Point USA.
为“美国转折点”摆摊。
And then Courtney starts shouting.
然后Courtney开始喊叫。
Neo-fascist Becky right here. Becky the neo-fascist right here wants to destroy public schools, public universities, hates DACA kids.
新法西斯主义贝基就在这儿。贝基这个新法西斯主义者在这儿想要摧毁公立学校、公立大学，仇恨“童年入境暂缓遣返”（DACA）的孩子们。
What's a neo-fascist Becky?
什么是新法西斯主义贝基？
A Becky is a white woman who weaponizes her whiteness and her white privilege.
“贝基”是一个武器化她的白人身份和白人特权的白人女性。
That's Courtney, who's a white woman, by the way. I wondered if Katie was familiar with the term.
那是Courtney，顺便说一下，她也是个白人女性。我想知道Katie是否熟悉这个词。
Did you know what that was?
你知道那是什么吗？
Yeah. I mean, I knew what it was just because it's slang, a lot of times what they call white girls, Becky. So I knew what she was getting at when she was saying that.
知道。我的意思是，我之所以知道是因为它是俚语，很多时候他们称白人女孩为“贝基”。所以我知道她说那话时指的是什么。
What was she getting at?
她指的是什么？
Just, I guess, calling me a little white girl or whatever. She's neo-fascist Becky.
我猜就是叫我小白妞什么的。她是新法西斯主义者贝基。
Katie and Courtney circled each other, one woman armed with a cell phone, the other with a poster board. And then--
Katie和Courtney绕着对方转，一个女人拿着手机，另一个拿着海报板。然后——
I flipped her off. The minute I did it, I was like, this is the kind of thing they're looking for. This is it. In fact, I thought to myself, well, if you take a picture, it will last longer.
我向她竖了中指。那一刻我就想，这就是他们要找的那种东西。就是这个。事实上，我心里想，好吧，如果你拍张照片，它会持续得更久。
You liked doing it.
你喜欢那样做。
They were there to be provocative, and I'm there to answer the provocation.
他们到那里是为了挑衅，而我到那里是为了回应这种挑衅。
On her first day, all of these scenarios Turning Point talks about happened to Katie. Somebody had tried to kick her into a free speech zone. A triggered liberal who didn't want her kind on campus had called her names and accused her of racism. And she reacted the way Turning Point teaches its soldiers to react, by taking out her camera and filming.
在她的第一天，所有“转折点”谈论的场景都发生在了Katie身上。有人试图把她赶进言论自由区。一个不想要她那种人在校园里的被触发的自由派辱骂她，指责她是种族主义者。而她的反应方式正是“转折点”教导士兵们做出的反应，拿出相机拍摄。
Courtney knew she was playing to type, the liberal academic who cried racism. But she didn't really care. She was there to make a scene.
Courtney知道她在扮演那种角色，那个哭喊种族主义的自由派学者。但她并不在乎。她到那里是为了制造麻烦。
Did she react at all when you flipped her off?
当你向她竖中指时，她有什么反应吗？
She laughed. She thought it was hilarious. And she got up in my face and she started walking with me to get me, to film me and stuff. And I think at one point I told her, you might get a better shot if you turn your camera landscape and not portrait. Hot tip. [LAUGHS] I mean, I was so indignant.
她笑了。她认为这很有趣。她凑到我脸前，开始跟我一起走，去录我之类的。我想有一次我告诉她，如果你横屏拍而不是竖屏，效果会更好。热心建议。[笑] 我的意思是，我当时太气愤了。
She's around my mom's age, from what I heard. So it was surprising behavior coming from someone who's a lot older than me.
据我所知，她和我妈妈差不多大。所以来自一个比我大得多的人的行为令人惊讶。
What was surprising about it?
什么行为令人惊讶？
That a woman who I presumed to be a professor at the university, who's in her 40s, would act like that, I guess. And then it started getting into-- we're saying the F-word, and you racist eff, you. It's my effing First Amendment, and then now screaming at people passing by. So at this point, I stopped recording. And I called one of my friends. And I was like, I don't know what to do.
我推测她是大学里的一位教授，40多岁，会做出那种行为，我猜。然后事情开始变成——我们说脏话，你是种族主义者混蛋，你。这是我的该死的宪法第一修正案，然后现在对着路过的人尖叫。所以在那一点上，我停止了录像。我给我的一个朋友打了电话。我想，我不知道该怎么办。
Katie says that there were some F bombs thrown around at the protest, things like, it's my effing First Amendment or you racist eff.
Katie说抗议中爆了一些粗口，比如“这是我的该死的宪法第一修正案”或“你这个种族主义混蛋”。
It is my effing First Amendment. It is my effing First Amendment.
这是我的该死的宪法第一修正案。这是我的该死的宪法第一修正案。
Did you say, "You racist eff?
你说了“你这个种族主义混蛋”吗？
I don't remember saying that.
我不记得说过那句话。
But there were F-bombs bombs flying around?
但当时到处都在爆粗口？
Oh, there were F-bombs flying around.
哦，到处都是粗口。
Eff Charlie Kirk?
去他妈的Charlie Kirk？
Oh, yeah. Eff that guy.
哦，是的。去他妈的那个家伙。
Things were getting ugly. Katie was feeling overwhelmed. She didn't really want to be there anymore, but she also didn't want to leave. She didn't want the liberal activist to think they'd won.
事情变得丑陋了。Katie感到不堪重负。她其实不想再待在那里了，但她也不想离开。她不想让自由派活动家认为他们赢了。
A woman walking by saw Katie surrounded by three protesters. One of them was being really aggressive. Katie looked upset. The woman, who worked for the university, mouthed the words, are you OK? Katie shook her head no. Then she started crying.
一个路过的女人看到Katie被三个抗议者包围。其中一个非常有侵略性。Katie看起来很不安。那个为大学工作的女人用嘴型说了：你还好吗？Katie摇摇头说不。然后她开始哭。
At this point, I was just a complete mess. It was-- [CHUCKLES] not the greatest situation.
在这一点上，我彻底崩溃了。这——[轻笑] 并不是最好的情况。
One of the other protesters was an English professor named Amanda Gailey. She wasn't chanting or swearing like Courtney. Instead, she stood off to the side and quietly held a sign that said, "Turning Point: Please put me on your watch list." It was a gesture of solidarity with the professors the group had singled out.
其中一个抗议者是一位名叫Amanda Gailey的英语教授。她不像Courtney那样大喊大叫或咒骂。相反，她站在一边，安静地拿着一块牌子，上面写着：“转折点：请把我放进你们的观察名单。”这是对该组织指名道姓的教授表示声援的一种姿态。
But when Katie got upset, Amanda decided to call a timeout.
但当Katie变得不安时，Amanda决定要求暂停。
I thought, this is not good. We don't want people to feel like this on campus. So I rolled up my sign. And I went over and asked her if she was OK. And I told her that I wanted her to know that I was not there to protest her and I had no hard feelings towards her. I was there to protest her organization. And I said, I would like to talk to you sometime, if you're up for it, when we don't have all these people around, in a non-hostile environment. And I said, would that be OK? And she said yes.
我想，这不好。我们不想让人们在校园里有这种感觉。所以我卷起标语。我走过去问她是否还好。我告诉她，我想让她知道我不是来抗议她的，我对她没有恶意。我是来抗议她的组织的。我说，如果你愿意，我们可以在没有这些人在场的时候，在非敌对的环境下谈谈。我说，那可以吗？她说可以。
Katie gave Amanda a piece of paper and the professor wrote down her email address.
Katie给了Amanda一张纸，教授写下了她的电子邮箱地址。
Did it make you feel bad?
这让你感觉不好吗？
Yeah. I think it did make me feel bad that she looked upset.
是的。我认为看到她看起来很不安确实让我感觉不好。
Courtney felt differently.
Courtney的感觉不同。
Oh, please. I don't care, because you've signed on with this group. If you're going to be politically active, there's no crying.
哦，拜托。我不在乎，因为你已经加入了这个组织。如果你要进行政治活动，就没有哭泣这回事。
Courtney draws a line between her identity as an activist and her identity as a teacher. She says she doesn't push her politics on her students.
Courtney在她作为活动家的身份和作为教师的身份之间划了一道线。她说她不会把她的政治观点强加给学生。
Why didn't you take that tact with Katie?
你为什么不那样对待Katie？
Because I'm not her teacher and it wasn't my classroom.
因为我不是她的老师，那也不是我的课堂。
When Courtney looked at Katie sitting at her Turning Point table, she didn't see a student who wanted to sign up classmates for a club. She didn't see a student at all. She saw a professional operative from a powerful national organization that wanted to eradicate from public education the people and ideas she held dear.
当Courtney看着坐在“转折点”摊位前的Katie时，她看到的不是一个想为俱乐部招募同学的学生。她根本没看到学生。她看到的是一个来自强大的全国性组织的专业特工，这个组织想要从公共教育中根除她所珍视的人和思想。
Turning Point was Fox News. It was the Koch brothers. It was President Trump. This was an invasion. And the soft spoken teenager handing out "I Heart Capitalism" stickers was the tip of the spear.
“转折点”就是福克斯新闻。它是科赫兄弟。它是特朗普总统。这是一次入侵。而那个分发“我爱资本主义”贴纸的轻声细语的青少年则是长矛的尖端。
The confrontation lasted about 20 minutes. Katie left the plaza, still upset. The protesters dispersed. And in another world, that would have been that. Maybe the student would have emailed the professor to clear the air. Maybe she would have lodged a complaint. Maybe an administrator or two would have gotten involved.
对峙持续了大约20分钟。Katie离开了广场，仍然心烦意乱。抗议者散开了。在另一个世界里，事情就到此为止了。也许那个学生会给教授发邮件解释情况。也许她会提出投诉。也许一两个管理员会介入。
In any case, you and I wouldn't have heard about it. But that's not the world we live in-- at least, not anymore. Instead, the outrage machine lurched into motion. That's what people in higher education sometimes call it, the network of right-wing websites that have emerged to pounce on stories big and small about liberals behaving badly on campus. Student activists send up a bat signal so conservatives around the country can see it and come running.
无论如何，你和我都不会听说这件事。但那不是我们生活的世界——至少不再是了。相反，愤怒机器开始运转。这就是高等教育界有时所称的，那个出现在各种右翼网站上的网络，用来扑向关于自由派在校园里行为不端的各种大小新闻。学生活动家发出蝙蝠信号，这样全国的保守派都能看到并跑过来。
That afternoon, Katie did interviews with Turning Point's news division and with Campus Reform, that news site with the student correspondents on campuses. She also tweeted her photos, including the one of Courtney giving her the middle finger. Her tweet said, quote, "Tabling for TP USA today and UNL faculty came to protest, screaming profanities. They won't silence me. I will continue to fight for freedom."
那天下午，Katie接受了“转折点”新闻部门和“校园改革”的采访。她还发了推特照片，包括Courtney向她竖中指的那张。她的推特写道：“今天为TP USA摆摊，UNL教职员工来抗议，尖叫着亵渎言语。他们无法让我沉默。我将继续为自由而战。”
Charlie Kirk saw her video and huddled with his team. They slapped a Turning Point logo on the video and Charlie tweeted it out, with a note saying, quote, "Intolerant left strikes again."
Charlie Kirk看到了她的视频，和他的团队挤在一起。他们给视频贴上了“转折点”的标志，Charlie发了推特，上面写着：“不宽容的左派再次袭击。”
That must have felt exciting.
那一定让人觉得很兴奋。
I guess it was, if I look back just a year before. I was following him on Twitter. But I mean, I think it was a big deal, what did happen. I started the conversation in the state of Nebraska that this is happening here. And it's not just happening at Berkeley. It's happening in Nebraska.
我猜是吧，如果我回头看一年前。我还在推特上关注他。但我的意思是，我认为这是一件大事，发生的事情。我在内布拉斯加州开启了对话，即这事正在这里发生。这不仅仅发生在伯克利。它发生在内布拉斯加州。
For conservatives who are anxious about campus politics, the University of California at Berkeley is Gomorrah, PC U, the bottom of the slippery slope. The University of Nebraska, on the other hand, is not typically a hotbed of political activism. There have been a couple Black Lives Matter rallies, and anti-abortion groups have marched there too. But Berkeley, it is not.
对于那些对校园政治感到焦虑的保守派来说，加州大学伯克利分校就是蛾摩拉，PC大学，滑坡底部的深渊。而内布拉斯加大学通常不是政治活动的热点。那里有过几次“黑人的命也是命”集会，反堕胎团体也在那里游行过。但伯克利，它不是。
When I asked people if the student body was liberal or conservative, they usually said neither. That a lot of the kids come from conservative backgrounds, but that most aren't very political, one way or another. The protest was on a Friday. Turning Point sent up the bat signal, and by Monday, there were articles about Courtney and Amanda in the The Daily Wire, The College Fix, Gateway Pundit, and Breitbart. University administrators got messages from furious Nebraskans.
当我问人们学生群体是自由派还是保守派时，他们通常说都不是。很多孩子来自保守背景，但大多数人并不那么政治化。抗议发生在星期五。转折点发出了蝙蝠信号，到了周一，《每日连线》、《大学修复》、《网关专家》和《布赖特巴特》上就有了关于Courtney和Amanda的文章。大学管理员收到了愤怒的内布拉斯加人的信息。
Hi, Gail. My name is Bill Forbes. I'm calling from out in Western Nebraska.
你好，Gail。我叫Bill Forbes。我是从内布拉斯加州西部打来的。
Well, furious for Nebraska.
好吧，对于内布拉斯加人来说很愤怒。
And I would like to recommend-- there needs to be an example, I believe, made of this professor. And I certainly would not insinuate that her livelihood should be removed from her. But I do believe that she needs to have an unpaid leave of absence. I would really appreciate hearing from you. Thank you so much, ma'am. Bye, bye.
我想推荐——我认为，需要把这位教授作为反面教材。我当然不会暗示应该剥夺她的生计。但我确实认为她需要无薪休假。如果能收到你的回复，我将不胜感激。非常感谢，女士。再见。
Others were more direct. A guy named Doug Kagan, who runs a group called Nebraska Taxpayers for Freedom, also wanted the university to do something about liberal bullies. And he wanted them to make some bigger changes while they were at it.
其他人更直接。一个叫Doug Kagan的人，他经营着一个叫“内布拉斯加纳税人争取自由”的团体，也希望大学对自由派欺凌者采取行动。并且他希望他们在做这件事的同时能做出更大的改变。
He suggested they eliminate some line items from their budget, including the women's studies program, the ethnic studies program, the LGBT programs, English as a second language, the diversity resources office, and money set aside for affirmative action. This is a good example of what can happen when Turning Point publicizes these incidents on campuses. It brings conservatives out of the woodwork with ideas about what the public universities should and shouldn't be doing.
他建议他们从预算中剔除一些项目，包括妇女研究项目、种族研究项目、LGBT项目、英语作为第二语言、多样性资源办公室以及为平权行动预留的资金。这就是当“转折点”在校园里公开这些事件时可能发生的事情的一个很好的例子。这把保守派从木制品中引出来，带着关于公立大学应该和不应该做什么的想法。
Katie never emailed Amanda Gailey, the professor at the protest who had offered to talk. In fact, in the week after the incident when the local talk radio host asked her if any of the protesters had tried to engage in dialogue, she didn't mention the email offer. She told them, there was no dialogue. I stood there as they were hurling these insults at me. As the story was retold, Courtney's behavior on the plaza was pluralized in a way that made it sound a bit like Katie had been accosted by a mob.
Katie从未给Amanda Gailey发邮件，那位在抗议现场提出谈谈的教授。事实上，在事件发生后的一周，当当地脱口秀主持人问她是否有任何抗议者试图进行对话时，她没有提到邮件邀请。她告诉他们，没有对话。当我站在那里时，他们对我进行这些侮辱。随着故事的重述，Courtney在广场上的行为被复数化，听起来有点像Katie被暴徒围攻了。
They were shouting at her, cussing at her, calling her names.
他们对她大喊大叫，咒骂她，叫她名字。
This is Hal Daub, a prominent Nebraska Republican who's on the university's board of regents. He's describing the scene on local talk radio.
这是Hal Daub，内布拉斯加州的一位著名共和党人，是大学董事会的成员。他正在当地脱口秀节目中描述这个场景。
And just really threatened her and bullied her to a point of tears. And now, she's a marked person and has, to some degree, perhaps have further safety issues because of these employees.
并且真的威胁她并欺凌她到流泪的地步。现在，她是一个被标记的人，由于这些员工，在某种程度上，可能还有进一步的安全问题。
Katie was no longer just a young conservative who loved America and hated big government. She's now a free speech crusader. The right has taken up free speech on campus as a rallying cry, pointing to speakers who had been shouted down or had their events canceled by universities. Katie was another conservative who had been silenced by a liberal bully.
Katie不再仅仅是一个热爱美国、痛恨大政府的年轻保守派。她现在是一个言论自由的十字军。右派已经将校园言论自由作为战斗口号，指出那些被大声喧哗淹没或活动被大学取消的演讲者。Katie是又一个被自由派欺凌者压制的保守派。
And so, two weeks after the protest, on another sunny Friday, she returned to the plaza, this time with a giant beach ball, a free speech beach ball.
所以，在抗议发生两周后，在另一个阳光明媚的星期五，她回到了广场，这次带了一个巨大的沙滩球，一个言论自由沙滩球。
It's just promoting free speech. It's a huge beach ball. And then anyone can sign it with anything they want to say. It's actually really cool. It's really fun.
它只是在促进言论自由。这是一个巨大的沙滩球。然后任何人都可以用他们想说的任何话在上面签名。这实际上非常酷。这真的很有趣。
Why a beach ball?
为什么是沙滩球？
I think just because it's easy to sign. It's just something fun, eye catching.
我想只是因为它很容易签名。它只是有趣、引人注目的东西。
She had gotten the gigantic beach ball-- it's 12 feet in diameter-- from the Leadership Institute, the organization that runs Campus Reform. Page 39 of the Turning Point chapter handbook includes detailed instructions on how to run a free speech ball event, beginning with how to inflate the ball with an electric pump and how many people you'll need to hand out markers, take pictures, and help you roll it around campus.
她从“领导力研究所”获得了这个直径12英尺的巨大沙滩球，“领导力研究所”是运营“校园改革”的组织。“转折点”分部手册的第39页包括了关于如何举办言论自由球活动的详细说明，从如何用电动泵充气，以及你需要多少人来分发记号笔、拍照和帮助你把它在校园里滚来滚去。
Nebraska state senator Steve Halloran walked the seven blocks up from the capital to pose for a photo with Katie. By the time he arrived, the giant beach ball was covered in messages from UNL students-- fuck communists, fuck Antifa terrorists, fuck Hillary, fuck Donald Trump, fuck everyone who's funding this. The senator managed to find space for his own message-- "Thank God for our freedom of speech."
内布拉斯加州参议员Steve Halloran从国会大厦走了七个街区来与Katie合影。当他到达时，巨大的沙滩球上已经写满了来自UNL学生的留言——去他妈的共产主义者，去他妈的安提法恐怖分子，去他妈的希拉里，去他妈的唐纳德·特朗普，去他妈的资助这个的所有人。这位参议员设法为自己的信息找到了空间——“感谢上帝给了我们言论自由。”
He and other senators had heard from constituents about Courtney's protest. They didn't like what they heard. Senator Tom Brewer wrote to the university president directly, quote, "This event is being watched very closely by the unicameral." In other words, we have our eye on you. Do the right thing.
他和参议院的其他成员听到了选民关于Courtney抗议的消息。他们不喜欢他们听到的。Tom Brewer参议员直接写信给大学校长，引用：“这次事件正受到议会非常密切的关注。”换句话说，我们盯着你呢。做正确的事。
The outrage machine had done its job. On Twitter, people called Courtney unstable, a loudmouth, a clown, a, quote, "tormented individual with an addiction to ignorance." 11 days after the incident, Courtney was called into a meeting with the university's executive vice chancellor, who told her that she would not be teaching anymore, at least not for the time being. Courtney wasn't being fired, the vice chancellor said, but the university was worried about her safety and the safety of her students. Courtney says the vice chancellor asked her if she would have done anything differently in retrospect. Courtney said no, no regrets.
愤怒机器完成了它的工作。在推特上，人们称Courtney不稳定、大嘴巴、小丑，引用：“一个沉迷于无知的受折磨的个体。”事件发生11天后，Courtney被召集到大学执行副校长办公室开会，副校长告诉她，她以后不会再教书了，至少目前如此。副校长说Courtney没有被解雇，但大学担心她的安全以及她学生的安全。Courtney说副校长问她回顾过去是否会做不同的事。Courtney说不，没有遗憾。
I think that if I had said to her, I apologize. I'm sorry. I shouldn't have done that. This is a terrible situation. But I didn't feel that way. And I don't feel that way. And I'm not going to apologize.
我认为如果我对她说，我道歉。对不起。我不该那么做。这是一个糟糕的情况。但我不是那么想的。我不那么想。而且我不会道歉。
Courtney's protest on the plaza was nothing out the ordinary for her. She's an activist, mostly for gun control. And she's testified against bills in the Nebraska state capital before. It was her mother who taught her to protest. But it was her father, a conservative, who showed her how to never give an inch.
Courtney在广场上的抗议对她来说并不反常。她是个活动家，主要为枪支管制奔走。而且她以前就在内布拉斯加州首府抗议过法案。是她母亲教她抗议的。但正是她身为保守派的父亲向她展示了如何永不退让。
Dad made talking politics a blood sport. It really was. I mean, we would be in the car and he would pick a topic, and we would debate it. So I was raised to do this. I was raised to talk politics. And my sister remembers it as being very abusive. She remembers it being like my father would back me into a rhetorical corner until I cried out of frustration, and then would take us out for dinner.
爸爸把谈论政治变成了血腥运动。真的。我的意思是，我们会在车里，他会选一个话题，我们会辩论它。所以我从小就被教导这样做。我从小就被教导谈论政治。而我姐姐记得这非常具有虐待性。她记得就像我父亲会把我逼进一个修辞角落直到我因沮丧而哭泣，然后带我们出去吃晚饭。
Courtney says her father's politics borders on fascism. Still, she says they're very close. Inevitably, news of her protest made it to his computer screen.
Courtney说她父亲的政治接近法西斯主义。尽管如此，她说他们关系非常亲密。不可避免地，关于她抗议的新闻传到了他的电脑屏幕上。
My dad found out about this on Breitbart and TheBlaze, because that's all he reads. And he called me. And he said, you know, you've always done this. You've always played with fire. And then he said, you're toxic. You're never going to get a job in academia. You probably will never be able to teach again. And I want you to know that you've done this to yourself.
我爸爸在布赖特巴特新闻和TheBlaze上发现了这件事，因为那是他读的所有东西。他打电话给我。他说，你知道，你总是这样。你总是玩火。然后他说，你有毒。你永远不会在学术界找到工作。你可能永远无法再教书了。我想让你知道，这是你自己造成的。
Some of Courtney's colleagues on the faculty did come to her defense. After she was removed from the classroom, about 50 of them held a small rally on campus, waving signs that said things like, "Don't gag our educators." The university had to answer publicly for what had happened. University president Hank Bounds went on a local talk radio show in Lincoln. The host, Coby Mach, speaks first.
Courtney的一些教职同事确实站出来为她辩护。在她被逐出课堂后，大约50人在校园举行了一场小型集会，挥舞着写有“别堵住我们教育者的嘴”之类的牌子。大学必须公开对发生的事情做出回答。大学校长Hank Bounds参加了林肯当地的一个脱口秀节目。主持人Coby Mach先说话。
She flipped her off. Hey, listen. That's protected by free speech, I think, as well.
她向她竖中指。嘿，听着。我想，这也受到言论自由的保护。
Doesn't make it appropriate.
并不意味着它恰当。
But she called her a neo-fascist Becky.
但她叫她新法西斯主义者贝基。
Yep.
是的。
And she said that a couple of times. And a "Becky" is referred to as a white woman, only you substitute the woman for a rather nasty name, a white woman who performs sex acts.
她说了几次。而“贝基”被称为白人女性，只是你用一个相当恶心的名字代替了女性，一个从事性行为的白人女性。
I have to say, one of the stranger outcomes of Courtney's protest was that it apparently sent the nice folks of Nebraska to UrbanDictionary.com in order to decode the meaning of "Becky." The definition that involves sex acts is not the first one listed, but it's definitely the one people gravitated toward. Courtney's rather academic definition, a white woman who weaponizes her white privilege, isn't on there at all. Regardless, the radio host thought she went too far.
我不得不说，Courtney抗议的一个比较奇怪的结果是，它显然把内布拉斯加州的好心人送到了UrbanDictionary.com以解码“贝基”的含义。涉及性行为的定义不是列出的第一个，但绝对是人们倾向于关注的。Courtney相当学术的定义——一个武器化她白人特权的白人女性，根本不在上面。无论如何，脱口秀主持人认为她太过分了。
And some say that that goes beyond intimidation, that that even borders on hate speech. So you understand why people want to know what's happening with this person that apparently is still on staff.
有些人说这超出了恐吓的范围，甚至接近仇恨言论。所以你明白为什么人们想知道这个显然还在工作的人发生了什么。
So I completely understand. I have been abundantly clear that it's inappropriate. That does not meet our standard of behavior.
所以我完全理解。我一直很明确，这是不恰当的。那不符合我们的行为标准。
And I think we're all glad to hear that though.
我认为我们都很高兴听到那个消息。
It's inappropriate.
这是不恰当的。
When President Bounds issued an official statement about the incident, he made this distinction. This wasn't about Courtney's right to free speech-- of course he supported that. No, this was about her lack of civility.
当Bounds校长就此事发表官方声明时，他做出了这种区分。这与Courtney的言论自由权利无关——他当然支持这一点。不，这是关于她缺乏礼貌。
In any case, we can all agree that Courtney called Katie a mean name. And a bunch of conservatives in Nebraska were offended. Or maybe they were triggered.
无论如何，我们都可以同意Courtney给Katie起了一个刻薄的名字。而内布拉斯加州的许多保守派被冒犯了。或者也许他们被触发了。
There's this phrase we kept hearing while reporting this story, "Nebraska nice." It was a marketing slogan. The state tourism commission used it a few years ago. But people seem to take it seriously. It's the plastic on the couch cushions that keeps the political mud being slung across the country from leaving a stain on Nebraska.
我们在报道这个故事时不断听到这个短语，“内布拉斯加好心”。这是一个营销口号。州旅游委员会几年前使用过它。但人们似乎认真对待它。它就像沙发垫上的塑料，防止在全国各地喷洒的政治泥浆在内布拉斯加州留下污渍。
Now, there are elements in Nebraska that threaten that niceness, that civility. After what happened to Katie, a former chairman of the state Republican Party, this guy, JL Spray, was worried about one threat in particular.
现在，内布拉斯加州有一些因素威胁到那种好心，那种礼貌。Katie发生的事情后，一位前州共和党主席，这个叫JL Spray的家伙，担心一种特别的威胁。
There's a group called Betsy Riot that I think emanates from the faculty at the university.
有一个叫“贝茨暴乱”（Betsy Riot）的团体，我认为源自大学的教职员工。
Betsy Riot is this sort of underground, punk, feminist collective whose members often conceal their identities with veils or creepy masks. They're kind of like PETA, nonviolent, but pretty in your face and willing to commit vandalism to make a point. In Nebraska, the group had posted signs comparing the Boy Scouts to Hitler Youth.
“贝茨暴乱”是那种地下、朋克、女权主义集体，其成员经常用面纱或令人毛骨悚然的面具隐藏自己的身份。他们有点像善待动物组织（PETA），非暴力，但相当当面并且愿意为了表达观点而进行破坏。在内布拉斯加州，该团体曾张贴标语，将童子军与希特勒青年团进行比较。
Another time, a group of Betsys wearing sunglasses and surgical masks marched at the Nebraska state capital, carrying a tube of ointment the length of a sedan with a label that read, "Preparation H for the flaming assholes in our legislature."
还有一次，一群戴着太阳镜和手术口罩的贝茨人在内布拉斯加州首府游行，抬着一管和轿车一样长的药膏，标签上写着：“给立法机构里那些燃烧的混蛋准备的H药膏”。
And they threw blood on the door of a United States senator, which I think is a terroristic threat.
他们还向一位美国参议员的门上泼了血，我认为这是一种恐怖威胁。
The blood was fake, actually. And it was found on the doors of both Nebraska senators after they said they would vote to repeal the Affordable Care Act. JL Spray thought Courtney was a member of Betsy Riot, which I told Courtney.
血实际上是假的。在他们说投票废除《平价医疗法案》后，在两位内布拉斯加州参议员的门上发现了它。JL Spray认为Courtney是“贝茨暴乱”的成员，我告诉了Courtney。
And he thinks that you're in Betsy Riot. And he thinks you were involved in throwing fake blood on some senators' doors. Is he right about that?
他认为你是“贝茨暴乱”成员。他认为你参与了向一些参议员的门上泼假血。他关于这一点对吗？
I don't know. He can think whatever he wants.
我不知道。他想怎么想就怎么想。
Are you in Betsy Riot? Is that something that you want to talk about?
你是“贝茨暴乱”成员吗？这是你想谈论的事情吗？
I have nothing to say about that.
关于这一点我没什么可说的。
Are you a fan?
你是粉丝吗？
Well, I know that Betsy Riot is an anonymous organization. And it's all over the country. They have a web page. You should totally check it out, BetsyRiot.com.
嗯，我知道“贝茨暴乱”是一个匿名组织。它遍布全国。他们有一个网页。你真应该看看它，BetsyRiot.com。
I have checked it out. It seems like the kind of page you would like.
我看了。它看起来像那种你会喜欢的页面。
Well, they're pretty badass.
嗯，她们非常坏。
Courtney, for the first time in the many hours we talked, had little to say.
Courtney，在我们交谈的许多小时里，第一次没什么话可说。
Steve Kolowich. Coming up, we move from the Brawl on the Mall to round two of this fight, the Fiasca in Nebraska. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Steve Kolowich。接下来，我们从“购物中心的大乱斗”转向这场斗争的第二轮，“内布拉斯加的闹剧”。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "My Effing First Amendment." If you're just tuning in, to review where we are, Turning Point USA has these tools-- video trainings and free speech balls and all kinds of stuff-- that they give to students so the students can go out and collect evidence and spread the word that there is a bias against conservatives on college campuses. And also, liberals be nuts.
这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“我的该死的宪法第一修正案”。如果你刚调到这里，回顾一下我们现在的处境，“美国转折点”拥有这些工具——视频培训和言论自由球以及各种各样的东西——他们交给学生，这样学生就可以出去收集证据并传播这样的消息：大学校园里存在偏见，针对保守派。而且，自由派也疯了。
Katie Mullen deployed these tools in the first half of our program and started a conversation in the state of Nebraska. In the second half of the show, we see where that conversation led. The conversation is supercharged emotionally for a bunch of reasons. First off, as maybe you've noticed, everyone in America hates everyone who disagrees with them right now.
Katie Mullen在节目的上半部分部署了这些工具，并在内布拉斯加州引发了一场对话。在节目的下半部分，我们看到那场对话引向了何处。由于种种原因，这场对话在情感上极度激化。首先，也许你已经注意到了，现在美国每个人都痛恨与他们意见不合的人。
But besides that, in Nebraska, there is something else to add to the mix. This college town is a blue dot in a big red state, which happens-- I have to say-- in so many places. And yes, I'm talking to you, Austin, Texas and Athens, Georgia, and Lawrence, Kansas and so many other towns.
但除此之外，在内布拉斯加州，还有别的东西需要加入这个组合。这个大学城是红色大州中的一个蓝色点，这种情况经常发生——我必须说——在许多地方。是的，我是在对你说话，得克萨斯州奥斯汀、乔治亚州雅典、堪萨斯州劳伦斯以及其他许多城镇。
And when fights like this happen on campuses in these red states, the fight can move so quickly, to whether people in the state can trust the state universities. Again, here's Steve Kolowich.
当这种战斗在这些红色州的校园发生时，斗争可以迅速转向人们在州里是否能信任州立大学。再次，这是Steve Kolowich。
Remember earlier, when I said that Courtney saw a Turning Point as an invading force with Katie as the tip of the spear? Well, some Nebraskans saw Courtney as the tip of a different spear. They were convinced there was something far more sinister behind her protest, a shadowy force bent on destroying the Nebraska they knew. That guy, JL Spray, who thought Courtney was part of Betsy Riot, he put it well.
还记得之前，我说过Courtney把“转折点”视为一支入侵部队，而Katie是长矛的尖端吗？嗯，一些内布拉斯加人把Courtney视为另一支长矛的尖端。他们确信她的抗议背后有某种更阴险的东西，一种致力于摧毁他们所知道的内布拉斯加州的影子力量。那个家伙，JL Spray，认为Courtney是“贝茨暴乱”的一部分，他表达得很好。
So I have a daughter at the university. And I'm paying tuition for her to understand critical thinking, to get a liberal arts degree, to learn how to think for herself. And what they're doing to her is, well, I think what they're trying to do is de-hickify her. That's also not in the dictionary, but basically beat the hick out of her so that she's just a good little liberal like the rest of them.
所以我有一个女儿在大学。我付学费是为了让她理解批判性思维，获得文科学位，学习如何独立思考。而他们对她所做的是，好吧，我认为他们试图做的是“去乡巴佬化”她。这也不在字典里，但基本上是把她身上的“乡巴佬气”打掉，这样她就和其他人一样是个好的自由派了。
The liberal bias of faculty is something conservatives have harped on for a while, and they're not wrong. As of 2014, nationally, there are more self-identifying liberal professors than conservatives and moderates combined. And in the last few years, the percentage of Republicans who say colleges are having a negative effect on the country has increased significantly to 58%.
教职员工的自由派偏见是保守派一段时间以来一直喋喋不休的事情，而且他们没错。截至2014年，全国范围内，自认为是自由派的教授比保守派和温和派加起来还要多。在过去几年中，说大学对国家有负面影响的共和党人比例显著增加到58%。
Katie became a source for Nebraskans who wanted to know exactly what was going on in the hallways at their state university. And where she decided to go next was probably the most liberal hallway of the most liberal building in one of the most liberal counties in Nebraska. In October, the chancellor told her that what Courtney did was an isolated incident and she wouldn't be formally disciplined.
Katie成为了那些想知道在他们的州立大学走廊里到底发生了什么的内布拉斯加人的信息来源。而她接下来决定去的地方，可能是内布拉斯加州最自由的县里最自由的建筑里最自由的走廊。10月，校长告诉她，Courtney所做的是一起孤立事件，她不会受到正式处分。
After that meeting, Katie started tweeting about the pattern of liberalism that she saw infecting the entire English department, Courtney and Amanda's academic home. She tweeted about signs on the English department building that said "No wall," "No ban," and "Resist." "Is this in a free speech zone?" she asked her followers.
那次会议后，Katie开始在推特上发布她看到的感染整个英语系的自由主义模式，那是Courtney和Amanda的学术家园。她发了关于英语系大楼上写着“没有墙”、“没有禁令”、“抵抗”的标语的推特。“这在言论自由区里吗？”她问她的关注者。
She tweeted about the department's mission statement and its core values, which include, quote, "affirming diversity and pursuing social justice." "Are they teaching English or teaching students to be social justice warriors?" Katie tweeted. People noticed. Campus Reform wrote about the English department. And in Omaha, Chris Baker, a conservative radio host, also picked up on the story.
她发了关于系里的使命声明及其核心价值观的推特，其中包括，引用：“肯定多样性，追求社会正义”。“他们是在教英语，还是在教学生成为社会正义战士？”Katie发推文说。人们注意到了。校园改革写了关于英语系的文章。而在奥马哈，保守派脱口秀主持人Chris Baker也捕捉到了这个故事。
If you go to Andrews Hall-- you know, Andrews Hall, a historic building there at the University of Nebraska. It houses the English department, other such things. And if you look at the photos on my blog, it looks like-- it appears that various administrators and grad assistants--
如果你去安德鲁斯厅——你知道，安德鲁斯厅，内布拉斯加大学的一座历史建筑。它容纳了英语系和其他此类事物。如果你看我博客上的照片，看起来——看起来各种管理人员和研究生助理——
Neo-fascist Becky right here.
新法西斯主义者贝基就在这儿。
--are decorating their windows with all kinds of communist propaganda such as "Resist." I love these people. They're resisting. What are you resisting? I'm telling you, man, that must be one of the most exciting, bedwetting drum circles where they come up with this crap. All right?
——正在用各种各样的共产主义宣传品装饰他们的窗户，比如“抵抗”。我喜欢这些人。他们在抵抗。你们在抵抗什么？我告诉你，伙计，那一定是他们想出这种废话的最令人兴奋的、尿床的鼓圈之一。好的吗？
I know that some are going to say, oh, Chris, it's a First Amendment right. No, it's not. You have a First Amendment right on your own time. You don't have a First Amendment right when you're working for me, the taxpayer.
我知道有些人会说，哦，Chris，这是宪法第一修正案权利。不，不是。你在自己的时间有宪法第一修正案权利。当你为我，纳税人工作时，你没有宪法第一修正案权利。
He's wrong, by the way. All Americans have a First Amendment right, even the ones who work for Chris Baker. A public university can't tell its employees not to express personal political viewpoints. It can make certain rules about how to express those views. They can put reasonable limits on where you can hang a banner. But those rules can't be based on what the banner says. Teachers don't give up their First Amendment rights when they take the job.
顺便说一下，他错了。所有美国人都有宪法第一修正案权利，即使是那些为Chris Baker工作的人。公立大学不能告诉其员工不要表达个人政治观点。它可以制定某些关于如何表达这些观点的规则。他们可以对你悬挂横幅的位置施加合理的限制。但这些规则不能基于横幅上写着什么。教师在接受工作时并不会放弃他们的宪法第一修正案权利。
President Hank Bounds went on the radio and defended the English department. He said diversity is something a university should strive for. But Katie kept her eyes peeled for evidence of liberalism in the English department.
Hank Bounds校长在电台为英语系辩护。他说多样性是大学应该追求的东西。但Katie一直睁大眼睛寻找英语系存在自由主义的证据。
A few months later, she took a picture of a sign that listed a bunch of different minority groups. It said, "Students of color, you are welcome here. Queer students, non-neurotypical students, Muslim and non-Christian students, you are welcome here." In the bottom left-hand corner of the sign was a woman's torso made of letters which spell, "My body, my business, motherfucker."
几个月后，她拍了一张写着一系列不同少数群体名单的标志的照片。上面写着，“有色人种学生，欢迎来到这里。酷儿学生、非神经典型学生、穆斯林和非基督教学生，欢迎来到这里。”在标志的左下角是一个由字母组成的女性躯干，拼写为，“我的身体，我的生意，混蛋。”
At the bottom where it said, my body, my business, mother-effer, I think that caught my eye a lot too, just the foul language of it. And just, I think, what else-- the fact it said Muslim, non-Christian. It specified non-Christian students. I mean, I can understand where it's coming from. And I totally agree that this place should be-- all are welcome here. But it did leave out some Christian white males. It was just kind of like, is this appropriate?
在底部，写着“我的身体，我的生意，混蛋”的地方，我想那也吸引了我的目光，只是因为那脏话。还有，我想，还有什么——事实上它提到了穆斯林，非基督教。它特别指出了非基督教学生。我的意思是，我能理解它的来源。而且我完全同意这里应该是——这里欢迎所有人。但它确实漏掉了一些白人基督教男性。这就像，这恰当吗？
It strikes me that what you're doing in the English department is to police what people in the English department say, at least in posters.
给我的印象是，你在英语系所做的是去监管英语系里人们说的话，至少在海报上是这样。
That's utterly wrong.
那完全错了。
Why is that wrong?
为什么那错了？
I'm not policing their thoughts. I'm not policing what they say. I just don't find it appropriate to have foul language up at their place of work, my place of schooling. I mean, so many students are going through school, don't really know where they stand, don't really know what they believe in. It's important that we're not spewing out this, I guess, hate almost towards Republicans and the other side.
我不是在监管他们的思想。我不是在监管他们说的话。我只是觉得在他们的工作地点，我的求学地点，贴上脏话不恰当。我的意思是，这么多学生在经历学业，真的不知道自己的立场，真的不知道自己信仰什么。重要的是我们不要喷出这种，我想，几乎是对共和党人和另一方的仇恨。
Katie was offended by the effing poster and she worried that the English department was giving itself an unfair advantage in the battle for the minds of UNL's impressionable young students. Her new friends, the state senators, agreed. Senator Tom Brewer believed that the University of Nebraska should, quote, "reflect and respect the beliefs and values of all Nebraskans."
Katie被那个该死的海报冒犯了，她担心英语系在争夺UNL易受影响的年轻学生思想的斗争中给予了自己不公平的优势。她的新朋友，州参议员们，表示同意。Tom Brewer参议员认为内布拉斯加大学应该，引用：“反映并尊重所有内布拉斯加人的信仰和价值观。”
Senator Steve Halloran started working on a bill that would require the university to punish protesters who drown out free speech on campus, with harsher penalties for repeat offenders. If the bill passed, the university would have to create something called a Committee on Free Expression. Essentially, the committee would do what Turning Point did, report out any incidents where free speech was stepped on by anyone else in an annual summary for the governor and the legislature.
Steve Halloran参议员开始起草一项法案，要求大学惩罚在校园里淹没言论自由的抗议者，对惯犯进行更严厉的处罚。如果法案通过，大学将不得不创建一个名为“言论表达委员会”的机构。本质上，该委员会将做“转折点”所做的事情，在提交给州长和议会的年度总结中报告任何被其他人践踏言论自由的事件。
Senator Halloran invited Katie Mullen to weigh in, telling a local newspaper that she met with his staff at least a dozen times to talk about it. In January, there was a hearing on the bill. A bunch of people showed up to testify against it, including professors from UNL. Many testified that it would have a chilling effect on free speech at the school. Some alleged that the senators were trying to crack down on the speech of liberal faculty members.
Halloran参议员邀请Katie Mullen发表意见，告诉当地一家报纸，她与他的工作人员至少开了十几次会来讨论这件事。一月，法案进行了听证会。一群人站出来反对它，包括UNL的教授。许多人作证说它会对学校的言论自由产生寒蝉效应。有些人声称参议员们正试图压制自由派教职员工的言论。
One law professor said the bill was alarmingly vague. He worried that it could lead to the government influencing what teachers discuss in the classroom. And weirdly, that fear sort of came true right there in the hearing room. Senator Mike Groene, the chair of the education committee, questioned some of the UNL faculty members about the politics of the English department. Amanda Gailey was one of them.
一位法律教授说该法案令人震惊地含糊不清。他担心这会导致政府影响教师在课堂上讨论什么。而且奇怪的是，这种恐惧在听证室里成真了。教育委员会主席Mike Groene参议员询问了一些UNL教职员工关于英语系政治的问题。Amanda Gailey就是其中之一。
Well, I will give you a chance, because it's out there about the website for the university.
好吧，我会给你机会，因为它在大学网站上。
It's out there?
它在外面？
On the English department. And it's got very little to do with Shakespeare or Chauncey or any of those people.
在英语系上。它与莎士比亚或乔叟或这些人中的任何一个几乎没有关系。
Have you looked at our course catalog, sir?
你读过我们的课程目录吗，先生？
Oh, I was just talking about--
哦，我只是在谈论——
Do you realize that a class on Shakespeare is taught, I believe, every semester in our department? And that when I listened to inexpert outsiders criticizing our curriculum for teaching social justice issues last fall, I was in the middle of teaching T.S. Eliot, Walt Whitman, and Emily Dickinson in my courses. Because the people leading this attack have absolutely no interest in--
你意识到关于莎士比亚的课，我相信，在我们系每个学期都在教吗？而且，当我去年秋天听到外行的专家批评我们的课程教学社会正义问题时，我正在教T.S.艾略特、沃尔特·惠特曼和艾米莉·狄金森的课程。因为发动这场攻击的人对——完全没有兴趣——
Courtney watched from the front row while Amanda defended the English department at this hearing that was supposed to be about free speech.
Courtney在前排看着Amanda在这次本应关于言论自由的听证会上为英语系辩护。
Shakespeare and Chauncey, stupid.
莎士比亚和乔叟，笨蛋。
Free speech is supposed to be one of the few remaining ideas in American politics that everyone can agree on. But free speech doesn't solve political conflicts. It creates them. Solving them requires more advanced tools like trust, humility, dialogue, listening. A law professor testified that the free speech bill was unconstitutional. And at the end of the day, it didn't make it out of committee.
言论自由本应是美国政治中少数几个每个人都能同意的剩余思想之一。但言论自由不能解决政治冲突。它制造了冲突。解决它们需要更高级的工具，比如信任、谦逊、对话、倾听。一位法律教授作证说言论自由法案是违宪的。到最后，它没有走出委员会。
But the idea of the bill, that there needs to be oversight over how public universities deal with speech, has taken hold around the country. Similar bills have been proposed in a lot of states-- Arizona, Georgia, Michigan, Wisconsin, others too, all based on the same script developed by a conservative think tank called the Goldwater Institute. But political pressure does count for something. And before it was all over, the conservatives would win a significant victory against the university.
但是该法案的想法，即需要对公立大学如何处理言论进行监督，已经在全国范围内扎根。在许多州都提出了类似的法案——亚利桑那州、乔治亚州、密歇根州、威斯康星州，还有其他州，全部基于一个名为“戈德华特研究所”的保守派智库开发的剧本。但政治压力确实算数。在一切结束之前，保守派将赢得对大学的一场重大胜利。
In the fall, Courtney was called into a meeting in the chancellor's office.
秋季，Courtney被召集到校长办公室开会。
Morning, Courtney.
早上好，Courtney。
Morning.
早上好。
How are you?
你好吗？
Fine, thank you. How are you doing, chancellor?
挺好的，谢谢。你好吗，校长？
Courtney secretly recorded it. During the meeting, Chancellor Green showed her security camera footage that captured her protest. He acknowledged that the protest went down exactly as Courtney had described. Then he made a confession of sorts.
Courtney秘密录下了它。在会议期间，Green校长向她展示了捕捉到她抗议的监控录像。他承认抗议过程完全像Courtney描述的那样。然后他做了一种承认。
I will not hide the fact, nor is there reason to hide the fact, that there was tremendous political pressure through this. As there was, and you saw it. There were political figures that were weighing in on this all the way to DC.
我不会隐瞒这一事实，也没有理由隐瞒这一事实，即在这方面存在巨大的政治压力。就像存在的那样，而且你看到了。有政治人物介入此事，一直到华盛顿特区。
Still, he was hopeful that Courtney would be able to return quietly to the classroom for the spring semester. But then something else came up that put the university back on the defensive. The conservative press had gotten ahold of some emails sent between university officials in the wake of the Katie Mullen incident.
尽管如此，他仍希望Courtney能够在春季学期悄悄回到课堂。但随后又发生了别的事情，使大学回到了防守地位。保守派媒体在Katie Mullen事件后获得了大学官员之间发送的一些电子邮件。
One retired administrator wrote, quote, "I don't think it's safe to be conservative on our campus. Too many faculty espouse their personal political views as gospel in classrooms where their views have no relevance." The university worried this would look like a smoking gun, proof that they were trying to de-hickify the students.
一位退休的管理员写道，引用：“我不认为在我们的校园里做保守派是安全的。太多的教职员工在课堂上把他们的个人政治观点当作福音，而这些观点与课堂无关。”大学担心这看起来像是确凿的证据，证明他们试图“去乡巴佬化”学生。
To get ahead of that potential scandal, President Bounds shared the email with every state senator and the governor, along with an apology and a pledge to study the political climate on campus. And Chancellor Green called Courtney back into his office.
为了领先于那场潜在的丑闻，Bounds校长与每位州参议员和州长分享了这封电子邮件，并附上了道歉和研究校园政治气候的承诺。Green校长把Courtney又叫回了办公室。
Thank you for coming in on very short notice. The disruption this continues to cause to our campus, that traces back to this incident, is significant. It is not going away. I mean, it's getting worse. We can't put you back in the classroom.
谢谢你这么匆忙赶来。这件事给我们的校园持续造成的混乱，可以追溯到那次事件，是非常严重的。它不会消失。我的意思是，它变得越来越糟。我们不能让你回到课堂了。
He assured Courtney that the decision had nothing to do with her scholarship or her teaching ability. She had gotten great reviews from her students. This was just politics.
他向Courtney保证，这一决定与她的学术水平或教学能力无关。她从学生那里得到了很好的评价。这纯粹是政治。
This is purely about that we are very concerned, if we put you back in the classroom, we're going to continue to suffer damage. I just have to be honest with you. And it traces back to the incident and the behavior in the incident.
这纯粹是因为我们非常担心，如果我们让你回到课堂，我们将继续遭受损害。我必须对你诚实。这可以追溯到那次事件以及事件中的行为。
And we can't put it to bed. We just can't. We've tried. We tried every way we know how to address it. We think we have addressed it. We think we have appropriately addressed it. But it will not go away.
我们无法让它平息。我们做不到。我们试过了。我们尝试了所有我们知道的方法来处理它。我们认为我们已经处理了它。我们认为我们已经适当地处理了它。但它不会消失。
We're in an environment that none of us have ever been in before. And I mean that broadly, but also I mean it academically. I mean, we're in a time that we've never been in before, in our lifetimes.
我们处于一个我们从未处于过的环境中。不仅从广泛意义上，而且在学术上也如此。我的意思是，我们处于一个我们有生之年从未处于过的时代。
How did you feel when you left that meeting?
你离开那次会议时有什么感觉？
[CHUCKLES] Like I had been fired.
[轻笑] 就像我被解雇了一样。
Courtney wasn't technically fired. She was reassigned to non-teaching work for the spring, with pay, like a problem cop sent to desk duty. Chancellor Green told us the official reason was, quote, "potential disruption to the academic environment." He was scared her classroom might become a target for political agitators who wanted to keep the fight going.
Courtney在技术上没有被解雇。她在春季被重新分配到非教学工作，有工资，就像一个被派去坐办公室的问题警察。Green校长告诉我们，官方理由是，引用：“对学术环境的潜在破坏。”他担心她的课堂可能会成为那些想要继续战斗的政治煽动者的目标。
What was the hardest part for you about not being able to teach?
关于不能教书，对你来说最困难的部分是什么？
I just really like my students. I like what I do. And it bothers me that I'll never probably be able to do it again. I am afraid of that. It's a big part of my identity, you know? And it really bothers me that I'm not in the classroom anymore because of these jerks, because their goal is to remove people like me from the classroom.
我只是真的很喜欢我的学生。我喜欢我所做的事情。而且这困扰我，我可能再也做不了了。我害怕这一点。这是我身份的一个重要部分，你知道吗？而且这真的困扰我，因为这些混蛋，我不再在课堂里了，因为他们的目标是将像我这样的人从课堂中剔除。
The conservatives of Nebraska couldn't purge the English department of liberals, but they'd shown the university who is in charge. Courtney was gone from the classroom. It wasn't really the university's decision. It was theirs.
内布拉斯加州的保守派无法清除英语系的自由派，但他们已经向大学展示了谁是负责人。Courtney离开了课堂。这并不是大学的决定。那是他们的决定。
Where's Katie Mullen?
Katie Mullen在哪里？
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Come here, girl. Stand up, girl.
过来，姑娘。站起来，姑娘。
A month later, at the Turning Point conference you heard about at the top of the show, the one down the road from Mar-a-Lago, Joe Walsh, a conservative radio personality, was giving a talk in front of a few thousand conservative students. And he asked Katie to stand up and take credit for her great work that semester.
一个月后，在你节目开头听到的那个“转折点”会议上，在海湖庄园路那边的那个，Joe Walsh，一位保守派电台名人，正在几千名保守派学生面前演讲。他请Katie站起来，为她那个学期的出色工作领奖。
20-year-old Katie Mullen from the University of Nebraska at Lincoln turns 20 years old today, baby.
来自内布拉斯加大学林肯分校的20岁Katie Mullen今天20岁了，宝贝。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Hey! And again-- guys, I don't want to get in trouble. I know we live in a time when everybody's harassing everybody. But guys, she'd be a great catch.
嘿！再说一次——伙计们，我不想惹麻烦。我知道我们生活在一个每个人都在骚扰每个人的时代。但伙计们，她会是个不错的选择。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
She's adorable and she's a hardcore conservative, baby. She is a freedom fighter.
她很可爱，而且她是个铁杆保守派，宝贝。她是个自由战士。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Hey! God bless you. Every day, grab your musket and go to war. Every day, grab your musket and fight for freedom and limited government. It's your fight. It's your battle. God bless you. Thank you, everybody.
嘿！上帝保佑你。每一天，拿起你的火枪去战斗。每一天，拿起你的火枪为自由和有限政府而战。这是你的战斗。这是你的战争。上帝保佑你。谢谢大家。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I want to tell you about one other thing that was happening on the UNL campus this year. At the beginning of the spring semester, a Nebraska anti-fascist group posted a video online of a guy named Daniel Kleve, a white supremacist discussing white supremacy with some other guys online.
我想告诉你今年在UNL校园发生的另一件事。在春季学期开始时，一个内布拉斯加反法西斯团体在网上发布了一个叫Daniel Kleve的家伙的视频，一个白人至上主义者在网上与其他家伙讨论白人至上。
Trust me, I want to be violent. Trust me, really violent. But now is not the time.
相信我，我想暴力。相信我，真的很暴力。但现在不是时候。
It turns out Daniel Kleve is also an undergraduate student at UNL.
事实证明，Daniel Kleve也是UNL的一名本科生。
Just because I dress like a normie or whatever, a presentable person, doesn't mean that I don't train for boxing. It doesn't mean that I don't lift weights. It doesn't mean that I don't love violence, right? You don't have to look like a violent person to be violent.
仅仅因为我打扮得像个正常人或者别的什么，一个体面的人，并不意味着我不训练拳击。并不意味着我不举重。并不意味着我不热爱暴力，对吧？你不必看起来像个暴力的人就能暴力。
When the Kleve video went public, lots of people on campus were upset and scared. A few hundred students, faculty, and staff gathered on the plaza in front of the student union for an anti-hate rally. Members of the basketball team took warm-ups and t-shirts that said, "Hate will never win."
当Kleve视频公开时，校园里很多人感到不安和害怕。几百名学生、教职员工聚集在学生会前的广场上举行反仇恨集会。篮球队成员穿着写着“仇恨永远不会赢”的暖身服和T恤。
Some people called for the university to expel Kleve. The administrators said they weren't going to. He hadn't made any specific threats, and even hate speech is protected by the First Amendment. The university police force had done a threat assessment and decided that despite what he said in the video, he wasn't going to commit violence at UNL. There was no safety issue.
有些人呼吁大学开除Kleve。管理员说他们不会。他没有做出任何具体的威胁，甚至仇恨言论也受到宪法第一修正案的保护。大学警察部队进行了威胁评估，决定尽管他在视频中说了什么，但他不会在UNL实施暴力。没有安全问题。
Meanwhile, when Courtney Lawton was first removed from the classroom, the university said it was because they were worried about safety for her and her students. Some people say it was hypocritical to allow a violence-loving white supremacist to keep going to class, when they had so quickly ousted Courtney Lawton for flipping the bird and calling a student "Becky."
与此同时，当Courtney Lawton第一次被逐出课堂时，大学说是因为他们担心她和她学生的安全。有些人说，当他们如此迅速地将Courtney Lawton赶走仅仅因为竖中指和称学生为“贝基”时，允许一个热爱暴力的白人至上主义者继续上课是虚伪的。
African American faculty and staff and students and others-- Jews as well-- those persons were not valued as much as the situation with the student in August. There is a greater emphasis upon the welfare of white students.
非裔美国教职员工和学生以及其他人——犹太人也是——这些人的价值不如8月份那个学生的情况。对白人学生的福利有更大的重视。
This is Michael Combs, a professor of political science. He's been at the university for more than 30 years. In February, the administration held a series of meetings where students and faculty could speak their minds about everything that had happened. Michael Combs talked about his fear, while Chancellor Green listened.
这是Michael Combs，政治学教授。他在大学工作了30多年。2月，行政部门举行了一系列会议，学生和教职员工可以就发生的一切表达意见。Michael Combs谈到了他的恐惧，而Green校长听着。
I have never been afraid in a classroom. On Wednesday afternoon at 4:30, when my class was over, I looked around and I see it. There is a white supremacist on campus. I need to get my black handsome self out of this classroom.
我从未在课堂里感到害怕。在星期三下午4:30，我的课结束时，我环顾四周，我看到了它。校园里有一个白人至上主义者。我得让我帅气的黑人自己离开这个教室。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have never felt that. I am from Louisiana. I have lived with white supremacists and they mean business. And I guess I'm bothered by this notion that I'm safe because you say I'm safe. I have to feel I'm safe. You have to convince me that I am safe on this campus.
我从未有过那种感觉。我来自路易斯安那州。我和白人至上主义者住在一起，他们是认真的。我想这个认为因为你说我安全我就安全的观点困扰着我。我必须感觉到我是安全的。你必须让我相信我在这个校园里是安全的。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Everybody wants to feel safe at the University of Nebraska. Michael Combs wants to feel safe from violent white supremacists. Courtney wants to feel safe from right-wing state senators. Katie wants to feel safe from radical liberal professors. They were all free to speak up about their fears, and they all did. But only one of them had powerful people in Nebraska come to her aid. Speaking isn't the same as being heard.
每个人都想在内布拉斯加大学感到安全。Michael Combs想感到免受暴力白人至上主义者的威胁。Courtney想感到免受右翼州参议员的威胁。Katie想感到免受激进自由派教授的威胁。他们都可以自由地谈论他们的恐惧，他们也都这样做了。但只有其中一个人有内布拉斯加州的强大人物来援助她。说话并不等于被听到。
Steve Kolowich is a reporter at The Chronicle of Higher Education. We collaborated on today's story with The Chronicle. You can read the utterly superb print version that Steve Kolowich did at chronicle.com.
Steve Kolowich是《高等教育纪事报》的一名记者。我们与《纪事报》合作制作了今天的故事。你可以在chronicle.com阅读Steve Kolowich所做的绝佳印刷版。
[MUSIC - JAMES BROWN, "TALKING LOUD AND SAYING NOTHING"]
[音乐 - JAMES BROWN, "TALKING LOUD AND SAYING NOTHING"]
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu and our senior producer, Brian Reed. Dana Chivvis produced our story from Nebraska. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们今天的节目由Diane Wu和高级制作人Brian Reed制作。Dana Chivvis制作了我们的内布拉斯加故事。我们的工作人员包括Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala 和 Matt Tierney。我们的主编是Susan Burton。
Special thanks today to Brock Read at The Chronicle for Higher Education, Brian Bernys, Lawrence Jones, Hannah Scherlacher, Kelefa Sanneh, Ari Cohn, Daniel Burnett, Spencer Brown, Ben Terris, Alex Abdul, Kassy Dillon, Daniel Weldon, Madison Dibble, Chris Dunker, Joel Patrick, and Emma Doyle. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He knows what a horse eats.
特别感谢《高等教育纪事报》的Brock Read、Brian Bernys、Lawrence Jones、Hannah Scherlacher、Kelefa Sanneh、Ari Cohn、Daniel Burnett、Spencer Brown、Ben Terris、Alex Abdul、Kassy Dillon、Daniel Weldon、Madison Dibble、Chris Dunker、Joel Patrick 和 Emma Doyle。我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《This American Life》由PRX公共广播交易所发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他知道马吃什么。
Hey!
嘿！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周将带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。
LYRICS: (SINGING) Just talking loud and saying nothing. Just saying nothing. Just saying nothing. Shape up your bag. Don't worry about mine. My thing is together and doing fine. Good luck to you.
歌词：（演唱）只是大声说话，什么也没说。只是什么也没说。只是什么也没说。整理好你的包。别担心我的。我的事情在一起并且做得很好。祝你好运。